making pizza
with my friends
and we love
italy with our hearts in our hands
when we
make peace
hi it's me markiplier we spent 10 hours
doing this intro and we're just gonna
roll with it because we just came all
the way from italiano and we're here to
share with you the secrets of pizza
which if you didn't know originates from
ancient
estonia yes estonia where the history of
stone
baked pizza came from if you think back
in your family everybody probably has a
recipe for pizza but we do not
we are what you call pizza inept we're
pizza blind we don't know
we never knew we never saw
but we believe that anything is possible
and through dreams we can make
pizzas come to life and with me is my
friend tyler
the cheese shine when you think of that
creamy delicious melty cheese the oozing
suave nature of it
i can't help but think of tyler and his
chiseled
features and then who among them can
even
possibly best that ethan the crust
nestor oh yes
the very same as the one that made the
pancake
so many eons ago who knew he was so
talented
who knew he was so handsome who knew how
tasty he could really be
i did you want to know you want to know
why
it's me markiplier
the sausage
was not required on that one yes i know
shocked as you may be back from the dead
my sausage shall not be killed
and i am here to tell you the secrets we
may not be able to make pizza on our own
but combined
i think we can unlock the secrets and
may the best
man make the best pizza
here are the rules we have the
ingredients to make the pizza here and
we have this
easy use to allow us to not be hindered
by our blindness we have
three minutes to make the best crust we
possibly can and when that time is done
then
we shall have to place toppings upon it
and make pizza are you ready
[Laughter]
this is so serious yeah yeah don't laugh
are you ready of course good
then shall we begin three two
one
oh that's so weak good yeast are those
like actual bacteria in there no time
we gotta go live oh i didn't warm it
that's good enough live live
live yeast live
[Applause]
[Music]
wait i got this one
nailed it do a side by side on that one
guy doing it
exactly excuse me
[Music]
as the ancient italians used to say
grunting makes the dough so you grunt
yeah there you go are you trying to make
eye contact when you're doing that
no only with tyler
oh oh
good take it take it all
anybody know what movie that's from uh
uh beauty and the visa no
wrong it's sony
time oh boy
[Music]
go down oh my god that's so so tiny
i didn't know what they did oh
the italian gods have blessed us this
spread appeared
like magic in front of us so i think
what we need to do is
we need to take these ingredients and we
need to put this on our pizza
because we've been allowed we're on the
right track but
how to proceed we've got so many things
i guess
we all must go our separate ways now
before we do that i don't want to judge
here that's a really nice dough that doe
though
fantastic
i feel like you're trying to hide it
this is the thing with the flower i
don't know what you're talking about
what doe ah yeah that's my question oh
that you're referring
all right so what we're gonna do is
we're gonna do the toppings we're gonna
we have free form this is
our artistic expression wherever we get
to do whatever we need to do
and we'll do that and then we do that
and then that's the way we'll be done
make sense
your pack's still on how's your ass i
don't know oh you're low on battery
oh no oh you're good how am i oh you're
good yeah
you're about to die all right so just
have at it
are you gonna even have enough for pizza
i don't think so
you ever make pizza as a kid nope
we were too poor we couldn't afford
pizza we didn't even have an oven
we had what we called the brick and it
was this thing that we would sit on to
heat up
and you know it wouldn't get very warm
but at least it would have the
comforting
feel like
go for it the comforting feel of my
dad's ass on everything he cooked
i mean that's really what i cherished
the most about the stone
you know it was good it was good i
remember our coming of age when
my brother and i were all enough to sit
on the stone
the old fishbach family tradition i
don't know if any of you guys knew about
that one
but yeah that's what we did yeah i
didn't do that
what you're kidding me
oh you you you did you
it's sad so what i'm doing is i'm making
a physical recreation of the stone
from memory i've created
the the impression the ass cheeks left
on it over
it got worn down it was like a stoneware
cookware yeah you know it gets passed
down the flavor
you're not supposed to wash it you know
what i mean the
flavor of your diet
i can't do that ah i don't want to do
that with mine oh boy i remember oiling
up the stone
for papa
late night so i'd be there sitting
oiling the stone
down in his room
memories you know uh good family dinner
anyway nothing quite like a home cooker
you sure your family didn't do that
it seems like ethan's family suddenly
started to do that
oh boy no but i decided to do a
variation off of the traditional and
insert a ricotta stuffed crust
ricotta what stuffed crust oh
this feels like making lunchables except
somewhere worse
does your dough look grey no man
no i'm looking at ethan's oh yeah his
yeah no his looks
super weird
see i'm a simple kind of guy i like very
basic ingredients
oh yeah sure i like simple ingredients
simple traditional pizza ingredients
you know the good stuff the cheese the
sauce extra sauce
you know it's all about bringing the
flavor together you know what
if it's if it ain't broke don't fix it
that's what i always said you want some
bite
thanks you're welcome
look it's an elf i can't pick it up oh
god i should have made it on the pan
oh no my elephant oh no dad what have i
done
i'm going for the very controversial
but my favorite kind of pizza ham and
pineapple
and this ham let me tell you it's fake
ham
what
oh my god ah
that's tryptophobia ham ready
[Music]
um that looks like my pores
oh it's every layer oh my god
everyone who thought that was a good
idea oh my god hey
tyler do you want to share a pan with me
yes i will certainly share a panel
oh about done i need i need sauce
oh sauce you got it sauced up oh sauce
on the
after oh interesting uh there's it's a
multi-layer pizza so what i'm actually
gonna do is there's cheese underneath
stuffed crust
with some pepperoni to add some flavor
to the sauce and then i'm also going to
put
cheese pepperoni and then cheese on top
okay now we're done yep it's like a
little bush
all right i think we're ready to put it
in
[Music]
all mm-hmm i think i can slot this thing
right in there
yeah that's the good stuff oh yeah and
uh
now we wait for the deliciousness of the
results
they're gonna be good it's gonna be good
here's a sink for you
[Laughter]
oh fresh ah trim fresh
oh ethan yours looks that
we had some rising happening
no my dick
my precious dick oh
no ah the tip the boob
oh god oh no oh
no quickly
tyler yours looks really good thank god
hey god
uh had the boober oh it's a shadow of
his former self
ah the dick oh god
he broke his heart i broke his dick
which is the heart as many people know
that crust is flaky
yeah it is you make little bites for the
whole family
i don't appreciate that i get to cut it
after the ham
cheese combo that's not gonna spread
that much flavor to you
today junior
[Music]
oh my god we could have made
12 more pies in this time
is that your italian unfortunately
so we got our pizzas here and we're
ready for judges calling all
impartial judges i'm sending a
telekinetic burst
no that was my call no it's my thing i'm
doing it
i'm sending a telepathic birth if you're
here and you hearing this
please come quick we need your help now
oh
hi it's them we made pizzas for you
that you get to eat that's what these
are yeah they're pizzas
you see which one would you like to try
first or actually let's do
we're going to judge on three categories
here look
the overall aesthetic the taste
blindfold taste test
and the yours is going to taste like
pineapple debatable
let me get done here sorry sorry the
crust
the overall presentation and taste
that's what it's got to be about
those are the three categories of pizza
good so start over here with ethan's
yeah because i don't want this to be the
last thing that i taste
should
just to get some moisture in there
how is she flaking
like a biscuit yeah not bad though
but we did take those right out of the
oven
you burned yourself yeah i was wondering
no it's just flour from out there all
right eating the crust
very flaky it is flaky it's not quite
pizza crust though
no it's a bit more of a croissant
with some butter yeah but the integrity
of this is
non-existent okay all right so
for mine i pre i call it the broken
heart
ah my my my cherished memories
of pizza as a child now presented to you
is this bowl now yeah like the crust
itself is beautiful
thank you that's a nice burnt cheese
feed each other
it's not bad it's really not bad
it tastes like pizza yeah the crust is a
little it's good
yeah it's just wait what
but it's a little nothing yeah it's very
flowery
that's what it is it's just very thick
and flowery but there's a good
sauce to crust ratio that was lacking
[Laughter]
i won't but i could thank thank you
thank you so here we have the
miniaturized
stuffed crust multi-layered pizza pie
for this one you eat backwards
[Music]
that's pretty good yeah the crust is a
little
soft yeah it's definitely it's got a
little doughy yeah
like those are flowery and more dry this
is just doughy yeah but it's also pretty
good
i like the cheese we did
[Music]
it looks like you took more than one
bite here one night is all you should
if that i want to try will you try
i would love to go for it careful
wait actually wait you go deliberate
let's judge each other's hang on
let's just look the categories are crust
taste and overall presentation
i gotta say i bet yours is the tastiest
yeah just judging by the two bites they
took
which kind of car are you doing i say i
win i think he went freezing
nope nope it's going to be a tie between
you and me for the crust
because there's the the thing yours
looks more golden
and they said mine was soft and i think
i think it might be because the amount
of sauce let me let me give this out
i'm gonna examine mine as well
oh that's good i mean that's not good
i'll be the judge i hate pineapple on
pizza shop man i try yours we're already
off to adventure go for it
[Music]
melt in your milk goodness right yours
tastes like pizza
thank you would you like to try oh yeah
that one lost a lot of cheese i think it
fell off that's okay
but
[Music]
it's just really good i think he's got
flavor i think he's got flavor on
lockdown definitely but if i do dry
i like my crust it's gonna be close
though so there are three categories
um taste it's gonna go to mark yay
really yeah yeah oh it was the most
pizza
second one is presentation yeah goes to
mark
yeah oh i really like the heart oh thank
you
and it's a nice big pizza yeah and crust
not too dry not too wet
was marks what was it yeah really
yeah we really liked it
yeah congratulations legitimately what
oh you guys i thought i thought for sure
you were gonna win taste no i would keep
doing this
well good competition
good job
good good work all around yep i'm
honored to win this prestigious award
i had such tough competition with tyler
here
what can i say you made i can't even say
that you made
pizza no i'm not sure about that either
but you tried i tried put your heart in
this
you want to try this recipe at home
follow him to the letter
someone write down your recipe in the
comments below
yeah wait good work all around good work
so thank you everybody so much for
watching and thank you for joining us on
this one adventure
make pizza at home for yourself and show
us what you made at home
thanks again everybody for watching and
as always we will see you
in the next video bye-bye
[Music]
bye